in indonesian waters off the coast of
the island of sumatra these fishermen
are trying to do whatever they can to
help people in desperate need this
vessel carrying more than 100 rohingya
refugees was spotted near aceh province
on sunday local fishermen said they felt
sorry for those on board particularly
the young children
according to our radio communication
they are weak someone died some are sick
including many children and the elderly
are getting weaker according to our
information they've been at sea for 28
days
[Music]
fishermen told al jazeera they have been
providing food medicine and water to
those on board but have not been allowed
to help them get to shore
local authorities in aceh say they will
assist the rohingya and give them
essential supplies but won't allow them
into the country
the job of the navy is to secure our
border
the rohingya are not indonesian citizens
we cannot bring them in even as refugees
this is in line with government policy
police say the rohingya were trying to
reach malaysia
thousands of rohingya have fled myanmar
to neighbouring bangladesh in recent
years escaping a military crackdown that
the un says amounts to genocide facing
poverty in crowded refugee camps many
try to reach safety in southeast asian
countries
last year a group of rohingya refugees
was saved by fishermen and brought to
shore after their boat broke down near
aceh but some fishermen told al jazeera
they were afraid of repercussions if
they attempted a rescue this time
indonesia is not a signatory to the u.n
convention on refugees and is seen as a
transit country for refugees making
dangerous journeys at sea
still human rights groups say indonesia
must do more as a regional power in
southeast asia
to push the boat back
is is a violations of international
obligations of indonesia i think
international law clearly imposes
obligations on states including
indonesia to protect human rights of
refugees arriving on their shores
the indonesian government has not
responded to al jazeera's requests for
comment and after so many days at sea
these desperate people still face an
uncertain future jessica washington al
jazeera jakarta